j'ai été formé à une seule chose
je n'ai aucune cause à défendre pour
devenir un jedi vous n'avez pas besoin
de partir dans une galaxie lointaine
très lointaine les maîtres de l'académie
du sabre laser ont organisé un stage
pour apprendre le maniement de cet amas
voisins-le-bretonneux et fondateurs sont
formels la discipline originaires des
etats unis un sport de combat à part
entière la pratique du sabre laser
quand elle a été codifié dans les films
star wars était surtout inspiré du kendo
également aussi un petit peu de
l'escrimé française et de la canne de
combat donc ces univers sportif et
martial font qu'il ya une codification
qui s'est effectuée au niveau des
frappes des parades de des zones de
touche est effectivement en fait
l'esprit du sabre il est vraiment
présent tout le temps avec la pratique
du sabre laser pour pratiquer ce sport
plusieurs éléments sont nécessaires
avant de se lancer dans les duels
un casque un plastron et des gants de
protection sont obligatoires le sabre
laser et lui fabriqué en polycarbonate
et si les mines avec un système de led
c'est pas un jouet c'est une vraie arme
entre guillemets c'est à dire que c'est
quelque chose d'assez dur qui peut
s'entrechoquer comme c'est pour ça qu'on
peut faire de la compétition des duels
ce stage organisé pour la première fois
dans le département des yvelines a réuni
une vingtaine de padawan ces visuels
c'est
convivial donc c'est intéressant c'est
agréable bon après c'est 10 sport aussi
quoi donc
et s'y attendait un peu moins à 9 heures
du matin mais mais bon ça fait plaisir
un très bon construit ça a l'air très
pro otan dans les techniques tant dans
l'enseignement etc
il ya des vins technique donc quand on
aime stores large et puis quand on veut
faire du sport à ce moment il ya un
aspect très ludique et être très amusant
parce que du coup on met un pied dans
l'univers entier ce sport compte déjà
plus de dix clubs en france et 350
pratiquants réguliers dans l'hexagone
une fédération française a également vu
le jour en 2015
après quelques séances d'entraînement
ces apprentis du viendront sans doute
les prochains luke skywalker